uni contre l'oubli 3 ans après son
assassinat le souvenir de Samuel paatti
était toujours présent hier soir
àonflant saint-onorine près de 400
personnes étaient réunies pour rendre
hommage au professeurs
d'histoire-géographie pour nous
Conflanais ce rassemblement est
particulier car elle ramène chacune et
chacun d'entre nous à cette terrible
soirée du 16 octobre 2020 après
l'hommage rendu par le maire de la ville
une minute de silence a été observé en
souvenir du professeur assassiné le le
16 octobre 2020 par un terroriste
islamiste un moment solennel est rempli
d'émotion auxquelles il était important
d'assister pour les personnes présentes
on était ind dé il y a 3 ans on est on
reste dans le même état d'esprit et ce
n'était pas pensable de ne pas venir
même moi je suis vraiment horrifié
j'habite à 200 m de l'endroit où il a
été assassiné je passe à cet endroit
bien sûr presque tous les jours et j'ai
du mal à me remettre Samuel pattil est
mort alors que c'est injuste et en fait
c'est juste quelqu'un qui a déformé la
phrase un temps de recueillement
nécessaire aussi pour réaffirmer les
valeurs de la République et de la
liberté c'est important ce moment de de
rassemblement et de recueillement aussi
pour ne jamais oublier à quel point
l'obscurantisme pouvait faire mal et
c'est aussi une manière de dire que nous
ne céderons pas face à ça que nous
restons unis que nous restons debout
collègues anciens élèves et conflanis
ont ensuite déposé des gerbes de fleurs
devant le monument pour la liberté
d'expression érigé en mémoire de
[Musique]
l'enseignant une façon d'aider les
Conflanais à tourner la page mais à ne
jamais
oublier